certaines libération d'otages aurait
sans doute pu se dérouler et intervenir
beaucoup plus tôt mais il faut savoir
que des contentieux politiques
militaires également des contentieux
financiers ont souvent bloqué l'issue
des négociations
à ces blocages se sont également ajoutés
des actes de terrorisme qui ont fait
malheureusement monter la pression
explications de jean marc il use au
coeur du contentieux franco-iranien il
ya d'abord une guerre celle que se
livrent depuis huit ans l'irak et l'iran
plusieurs centaines de milliers de morts
et de blessés or la france après l'urss
et le deuxième fournisseur d'armes de
l'irak
facturé en milliards de francs mirage
missiles hélicoptères et surtout des
systèmes de guidage électronique
terriblement efficace après avoir
d'abord exigé sans succès la suspension
pure et simple de l'aide française à
l'irak l'iran et les groupes terroristes
qui le soutiennent réclameront une
politique plus équilibrée
en clair de pouvoir acheter les mêmes
armes que leurs ennemis irakien la
france a toujours dit non mais à paris
comme ailleurs
aucun gouvernement n'est chapeau aux
accusations de vente clandestine d'armes
à l'iran deuxième source de conflit la
présence en france d'opposants iraniens
condamnés par le régime de téhéran
asile politique pour l'ancien chef de
gouvernement banny ça dans 81 et surtout
pour massoud radjavi chef des
moudjahidines du peuple
son expulsion en juin 86 permettra la
libération de philippe rochot georges en
scène l'expulsion de ses partisans en
décembre 87 sera un nouveau signe de la
poursuite des interminables tractations
entre paris et téhéran
troisième source de conflits les actes
terroristes monte à téhéran cinq
terroristes emprisonnés en france après
un attentat sanglant en juillet 80 ne
seront jamais libéré mais en novembre 87
wahid gordji numéro deux de l'ambassade
d'iran suspects de complicité dans les
attentats qui firent 11 morts et 150
blessés en plein paris en septembre 86
sera soudain lavé de tout soupçon son
départ de paris mettra fin à quatre mois
de guerre des ambassades et surtout
surviendra deux jours à peine après la
libération de roger auque et jean louis
normandin
le 25 mars 88 nouveau coup de théâtre
mohamed djouad gère un français
d'origine libanaise également soupçonné
dans les mêmes attentats de septembre 86
sera à son tour
libéré après un an de détention
libération interprété comme un signal de
paris aux iraniens et à leurs partisans
libanais quatrième contentieux le
contentieux financier
d'un côté la dette d'un milliard de
dollars contracté par la france aux
temps du shah d'iran
de l'autre les intérêts des firmes
françaises les et pendant la révolution
islamique
deux tiers de ces dettes remboursées par
la france en 86 peut être un troisième
demain si un accord existe enfin sur le
montant des intérêts payables par paris